This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. How do you cope with unhappiness and distress? It's a question humans have wrestled with for thousands of years. It's a foundational issue for many of the world's religions. It's also what we have kept you up at night this past week. Lots of us have techniques to deal with pain. We hang out with friends to make ourselves feel better. We exercise or turn to music.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。你如何应对不快乐和痛苦？这是人类几千年来一直在搏斗的问题。这是世界上许多宗教的根本问题。这也是过去一周里让我们彻夜难眠的问题。我们很多人都有应对痛苦的技巧。我们和朋友一起闲逛来让自己感觉好一点。我们锻炼身体或听音乐。
Some of us turn to drugs and alcohol. In recent years, researchers have run experiments to see what works and what doesn't work when it comes to dealing with distress. Some conclusions of this body of science are counterintuitive and some dovetail with lessons learned hundreds of years ago. Today in the next installment of our Happiness 2.0 series, we examine the difficult emotions that often sabotage our well-being. How to deal with distress?
我们中的一些人会借助毒品和酒精。近年来，研究人员进行了实验，看看在处理痛苦时什么有用，什么没用。这门科学的一些结论是违反直觉的，还有一些与数百年前学到的经验相吻合。今天，在我们“幸福2.0”系列的下一期中，我们将探讨那些经常破坏我们幸福感的困难情绪。如何应对痛苦？
This week on Hidden Brain. When Todd Caston was growing up on Long Island, his mom was the center of his emotional life. She raised him and his twin brother by herself. Todd's relationship with his mother has informed the next several decades of his life. He is now a psychologist at George Mason University and he studies the science of well-being. Todd Cashden welcome to Hidden Brain. So good to be here. Todd your dad left the family when you were a toddler. What was your relationship like with your mom? Well the way people refer to it was I was the mother's boy of my twin brother myself and
本周收听《隐藏的大脑》。托德·卡斯顿（Todd Kashdan）在长岛长大时，他的母亲是他情感生活的中心。她独自抚养他和他的双胞胎兄弟。托德与母亲的关系影响了他接下来的几十年人生。他现在是乔治梅森大学的心理学家，研究幸福科学。托德·卡斯顿，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里。托德，你还是个蹒跚学步的幼儿时你父亲就离开这个家了。你和母亲的关系是怎样的？嗯，人们的说法是，我、我的双胞胎兄弟以及我自己，
everywhere she went I was in her lap next to her holding her hand inseparable. I understand that she was unwell through much of your childhood. What what happened Todd? So this is from the perspective of a 13-year-old. And when you're told that your mom has breast cancer and you're told that there are these stages, none of it makes sense to you. And so for much of my childhood, as I remember it, is she was losing her hair, she wore wigs,
无论她去哪儿，我都坐在她怀里、在她旁边、拉着她的手，形影不离。据我了解，在你的童年时期，她的大部分时间身体都不太好。托德，发生了什么？所以这是从一个13岁孩子的视角来看的。当你被告知你妈妈得了乳腺癌，并且被告知有这些不同的阶段时，这些对你来说都没有意义。因此，在我童年大部分的记忆中，她都在掉头发，她戴着假发，
and I knew something was wrong, but the idea that there's the possibility that your mom might die is just not something you even consider. When Todd was 13, his mother was hospitalized. My grandmother took us to the hospital, my twin brother and myself. And when we got there, it was so excited because it had been days or weeks since we had seen my mom that we'd get to run into the room and go give her a hug. And when we got there, we were told that my mom didn't want to see us because she knew she was dying and she didn't want to taint our memories of what she looked like and what it was like to be with her. memories of what she looked like and what it was like to be with her. And if you can imagine through 13-year-old boys, we're going on our toes, waving our hands,
我知道出了问题，但你妈妈可能会死的这种想法，根本是你连想都不会去想的。托德13岁时，他的母亲住院了。我祖母带我们去了医院，我和我的双胞胎兄弟。当我们到达那里时，我们非常兴奋，因为距离我们上次见到妈妈已经过去了好几天或几周，我们终于可以跑进病房去拥抱她了。当我们到达那里时，我们被告知妈妈不想见我们，因为她知道自己快要死了，她不想玷污我们记忆中她原本的样子，以及和她在一起时的美好体验。记忆中她原本的样子和与她在一起时的体验。你可以想象，作为两个13岁的男孩，我们踮起脚尖，挥舞着双手，
trying to get her attention at the little glass window in her hospital door, and we're jumping up and down, and we could see her, and we could see that she was gaunt and pale, but she couldn't see us. And that experience has lingered so deeply in my psyche, where I could see the person I love the most and the person that gives me the most ability in my life. But that person has no ability to even notice that you're there. And that's the lasting memory, because that was the last moment that I sort of saw but wasn't able to interact with my mom. So you were in middle school when she died.
试图引起她病房门上小玻璃窗后她的注意，我们蹦蹦跳跳，我们能看到她，我们能看到她憔悴而苍白，但她看不到我们。这段经历深深地留在了我的精神世界里，我能看到我最爱的人，那个赋予我生命中最多能力的人。但那个人却没有能力注意到你在那里。这是一个持久的记忆，因为那是我最后一次看到但无法与妈妈互动的时刻。所以她去世时你还在读初中。
How did your school and your classmates handle what had happened? So this is something it's worth thinking about in the aftermath of death is my twin brother that I walked into school. People avoided eye contact with us. And if I saw one of my close friends and I waved at them, they give that halfway where their arm doesn't even go above their hip and then they looked away and kind of we were basically ghosted and we walked through this hallway wondering
你的学校和同学是如何处理这件事的？所以在死后这段时间里，值得思考的一点是，我和我的双胞胎兄弟走进了学校。人们避开与我们对视。如果我看到一个好朋友并向他们挥手，他们会那种半心半意地挥手，他们的胳膊甚至都抬不到臀部以上，然后他们就移开视线，基本上我们就像是被当成了鬼魂，我们走过这条走廊，心里在想
what to do with all these emotions and thoughts that are uncomfortable inside of us. I have no judgment of anyone because I had no idea how to respond either. In some ways, I have a little bit of beef with the school itself of making this announcement and a little bit of beef with the school itself of making this announcement and are setting yourselves up for having this awkward, uncomfortable social interaction where nobody is skilled and how to deal with grief, and we just walked right into that trap, my twin brother and I, and we didn't know what to say or do either. For the next several days, friends came over to Todd's house to offer their condolences. Todd and his brother
该如何处理内心里这些不舒服的情绪和想法。我对任何人都没有评判，因为我也不知道该如何回应。从某种程度上说，我对学校本身发布这个公告有点微词，我对学校本身发布这个公告和让自己陷入这种尴尬、令人不舒服的社交互动中也有点微词，因为没有人擅长如何处理悲伤，而我和我的双胞胎兄弟就这样直接掉入了那个陷阱，我们也不知道该说些什么或做些什么。在接下来的几天里，朋友们来到托德家向他表达哀悼。托德和他的兄弟
would bring them to an upstairs bedroom. And who knows what you're supposed to do at the age of 13. And my brother and I, not knowing what to do with these emotions, we just did karaoke, playing loud music, we're doing impressions of teachers, and every emotion existed except for grief in those absurd bedrooms. I close myself off from everyone. That moment of being able to see my mom in her last moments of suffering and not be seen is left thread where my capacity to love things, activities, people was there, but nobody was in a gain access to understanding me.
会把他们带到楼上的卧室。在13岁的年纪，谁知道你该做什么。我和哥哥不知道该如何处理这些情绪，我们只是玩卡拉OK，放着大声的音乐，模仿老师，在那些荒谬的卧室里，除了悲伤，什么情绪都存在。我把自己对所有人封闭起来。能够看到妈妈在遭受痛苦的最后时刻却无法被看到的那个时刻，留下一根线，我爱事物、活动、人的能力还在，但没有人能够真正理解我。
And so I lost myself in listening to heavy metal music and going into mosh pits and slamming it to other boys and some women at concerts, and then it switched to being interested in bodybuilding and weightlifting, and I became obsessively passionate about that. And then I spent many a day, which my grandmother never knew, where I would just sit in a softball field in a Friday Saturday night with a 12-pack or 24-pack of beer with my friend Martin or my friend Mark, or even by myself. And it was just oscillating between trying to numb myself
所以我沉迷于听重金属音乐，去进到疯狂冲撞的人群中，在音乐会上和其他男孩甚至一些女性猛烈撞击，然后转向对健美和举重感兴趣，我对此产生了痴迷般的热情。然后我度过了许多天，这是我祖母从未知道的，在一个周五周六的夜晚，我会和我的朋友马丁或马克，甚至一个人，坐在垒球场上，喝着一打或两打啤酒。这种状态在试图麻痹自己之间摇摆不定，
and just have as much entertainment as humanly possible just keep that negative stuff away. Perhaps you know people like Todd. Perhaps you know firsthand what it's like to look away from pain, to find distractions, laughter, entertainment, anything really, so long as you don't have to acknowledge the elephant-sized hurt in the middle of your heart. Notice also how the word conspires with us to look away from our distress. Todd's mother kept him from seeing her as she was dying because she wanted to spare him from pain. School friends were only too happy to talk about anything other than grief.
并尽可能地获得人类所能拥有的娱乐，只是为了把那些负面的东西赶得远远的。也许你认识像托德这样的人。也许你亲身体验过移开视线不去看痛苦、寻找分心事物、笑声、娱乐——只要不用承认你心脏正中间那个大象般大小的伤口，什么都行——是什么感觉。同时也请注意，这个世界是如何合谋让我们不去面对痛苦的。托德的母亲不让他看到她垂死的样子，是为了免除他的痛苦。学校的朋友们也非常乐于谈论悲伤之外的任何事情。
As Todd grew older, he found plenty of peers who were willing to drown sorrows in loud music and alcohol. All of this makes intuitive sense, of course. Pain is unpleasant. Grief can feel unbearable. When we come back, more of Tad's journey to understand the role of distress in our lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. When Todd Caston was a sophomore in college, he fell madly in love. The woman he adored was way, way out of his leak. Then something amazing happened. She agreed to go out with him. The woman had recently been engaged to be married, but her fiance had broken off the
随着托德长大，他找到了许多愿意用震耳欲聋的音乐和酒精来淹没悲伤的同龄人。当然，所有这一切在直觉上都是合乎情理的。痛苦是不愉快的。悲伤是难以忍受的。当我们回来时，将继续了解托德探索痛苦在我们生活中所扮演角色的旅程。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。托德·卡斯顿上大学二年级时，疯狂地坠入了爱河。他崇拜的那个女孩远比他优秀得多。然后奇迹发生了。她答应跟他约会。这个女孩最近曾订过婚，但她的未婚夫打破了这段
relationship. Todd was the rebound guy. That was just fine with him. He was ecstatic. This is my first love, sophomore year in college. I was in her apartment, and she was on the phone with her ex, and I could only hear her end of the conversation. I'm sitting on the floor and I'm thinking this will be a five minute conversation. And on this phone call, she's saying things such as, no, he's not that important to me.
关系。托德是接盘侠。但他觉得这完全没问题。他欣喜若狂。这是我的初恋，大二的时候。我在她的公寓里，她在和前男友打电话，我只能听到她那边的对话。我坐在地板上心想，这应该是一个五分钟的通话。在这个电话里，她说的话诸如：不，他对我不那么重要。
Of course, it's not like you. Of course, I'm not going to be engaged to him. Like he's just, it's something to do in the interim. And this goes on for, I'm going to say like 50 minutes, an hour and 20 minutes. And she hangs up that phone. And I'm only hearing her side of the conversation. And when she's finished, no apology, she just lunged towards me, kisses me. And I pretend as if nothing happened.
当然，他跟你不一样。当然，我不会跟他订婚。就像他只是，这只是过渡期找点事做。这持续了，我要说是大约50分钟，一个小时20分钟。然后她挂断了电话。而我只听到了她那一侧的对话。当她打完电话后，没有一句道歉，她直接扑向我，吻了我。而我假装什么都没发生过。
And I had this thought in my head of, this woman is so above my league. She's so physically attractive, she's so intelligent, she's so witty, I'm so lucky to have her that I just took all of this embarrassment and regret and self-loathing and dismay from this moment. And it was just like taking too fists at just shoving it down my throat and pretending. It didn't even exist. So we've seen two examples from your own life, Todd, where you were encouraged to look away from pain when you were a child, and you actively chose to look away from pain as a young adult. Soon after college, you trained to become a clinical psychologist, and you started working with one client who was a war veteran.
我脑子里有这样一个想法：这个女人比我优秀太多了。她外表太有吸引力了，她太聪明了，她太机智了，我能拥有她是多么幸运，以至于我默默承受了这一刻所有的尴尬、悔恨、自我厌恶和沮丧。这就像用双拳硬生生地把它塞进我的喉咙里，然后假装它根本不存在。所以我们看到了你生活中的两个例子，托德，一个是你还是个孩子时，被鼓励不要去看痛苦；另一个是你作为年轻人时，主动选择不去看不快。大学毕业后不久，你接受了临床心理学培训，并开始与一位越战老兵客户合作。
Tell me how you met this man, and what he said about his experiences in the Vietnam War. Yeah, this is at the Charleston Veterans Administration Hospital and in introducing himself to a group of about 20 other veterans. He mentions that he's a Vietnam War veteran, so we're talking 20 years after the war. And he told this story that when he came back and entered civilian life, his friends bought him tickets to a next game of just so excited that he survived and just to have him back in their lives and He's in the stands and if you've never been to a professional sporting event the The amphitheater goes black and then if it's a home team you've got this loud
告诉我你是怎么认识这个人的，以及他是如何讲述自己在越南战争中的经历的。是的，这是在查尔斯顿退伍军人事务医院，他在向大约其他20名退伍军人做自我介绍时。他提到自己是一名越战老兵，所以我们谈论的是战争结束20年后。他讲了这样一个故事：当他返回并进入平民生活时，他的朋友们给他买了一场尼克斯队比赛的门票，因为他们太高兴他活下来了，也为了欢迎他回到他们的生活中，他坐在看台里，如果你从未去过专业的体育赛事，体育馆会变黑，然后如果是主场球队，你会听到响亮的
Speaker introducing the players. There's pyro techniques and there's fireworks and explosions, and the diamond vision screen has all this huge sound effects and neon lights, and when this guy responds to the loud sound the noises, he jumps out of his seat, climbs below the bleachers, and is hiding where people drop their pretzels and spill their beer. And when the lights came back on, his friends found him there and they pointed at him and they left. And as he's telling this story 20 years later, he is crying tears streaming down his face. He looked at them, ran out of Madison Squaregarg, never spoke to those friends again, and never gone to a public professional sporting event ever again.
扬声器在介绍球员。有烟火技术、烟花和爆炸，大屏幕上有着巨大的音效和霓虹灯，当这个人对巨大的声音和噪音做出反应时，他从座位上跳下来，爬到看台下方，躲在人们掉落椒盐卷饼和洒啤酒的地方。当灯光重新亮起时，他的朋友们在那个地方找到了他，他们指着他并大笑。当他在20年后讲述这个故事时，他哭了，眼泪顺着脸颊流下来。他看着他们，跑出了麦迪逊广场花园，再也没有和那些朋友说过话，也再也没有去过公共职业体育赛事。
In some ways, the man was doing what Todd himself had done in his own life. In response to an emotionally traumatic event, he had withdrawn into himself. Clinicians were seeing similar patterns and patience across a wide range of emotional problems. After something bad happens, any contact with a source of distress, even the memory of the distress, can produce unpleasant physical and emotional reactions. As a result, the person does everything in their power to keep the pain at bay. One of the things that cuts across is the unwillingness to be in contact with ugly, undesirable thoughts, feelings, memories, even bodily sensations like an increased heart rate. And this was a person experiencing physical tension in
从某种程度上说，这个人做着托德在自己生活中做过的事。为了应对情绪创伤事件，他退缩到了自己的世界里。临床医生在各种情绪问题的患者身上看到了类似模式。在发生不好的事情之后，任何与痛苦源头的接触，甚至是痛苦的记忆，都会产生令人不快的情理和情绪反应。因此，这个人竭尽全力将痛苦拒之门外。其中一个普遍存在的普遍问题是不愿意接触丑陋的、不受欢迎的想法、感觉、记忆，甚至像心率加快这样的身体感觉。而这是一个在
their legs, experiencing their hands shaking in front of other people. I was trained to have a combination of two things. One was called narrative exposure therapy, which is a disorder does not define who we are and we can actually experience joy, meaning, and richness, and vitality even if we're suffering from a disorder. It's supposed to be the title or the subtitle of your story. You know, here lies Robert a combat survivor with post-traumatic stress disorder. Try to move it in the narrative of this doesn't define you. It's really chapter three, paragraph three and four of you were in war and it was difficult to come home and there were
双腿中经历身体紧张、在其他人面前经历双手颤抖的人。我接受的培训是结合两件事情。一是被称为叙事暴露疗法，即一种障碍并不能定义我们是谁，即使我们正在遭受障碍的痛苦，我们实际上也可以体验到快乐、意义、丰富和活力。这应该是你故事的标题或副标题。你知道，这里躺着罗伯特，一个患有创伤后应激障碍的战斗幸存者。试着把它融入这样一个叙事中：这并不能定义你。这实际上只是你经历过战争、回家很艰难的第一章第三节以及第四段，
some traumas that you experienced and so it's not you It's an event that happened so one part of the therapy is realizing there are other parts of the narrative that you're ignoring Your strengths your goals the things that matter most to you what you're gonna commit your life to and the other part of therapy is what's called behavior activation And that's instead of trying to change a person's thoughts or feelings, you say, what if we try to increase the number of potentially pleasurable activities and realize it just feels good. Just being around other people, especially when you're sharing things that are important to you and sharing your feelings. and by doing it as you take action with your body, the thoughts and the feelings will follow with it.
你经历了一些创伤，所以这不是你，这是一个发生的事件。所以疗法的一部分是意识到叙事中还有你忽略的其他部分。你的长处、你的目标、对你最重要的事情、你将为之献身的生活，而疗法的另一部分被称为行为激活。这就是说，不要试图改变一个人的想法或感受，而是问：如果我们试着增加潜在愉快活动的数量，并意识到这感觉很好，会怎么样？仅仅是和别人在一起，尤其是当你分享对你重要的事情和分享你的感受时。通过用你的身体采取行动来做到这一点，思想和感觉也会随之而来。
This form of therapy is designed to reframe the centrality of the distressing event in your mind. Instead of being the main attraction, it's now in the background. your mind. Instead of being the main attraction, it's now in the background. You try to focus on other activities, other goals. The distress isn't gone, but it's been moved from the front row of the picture to the third row. Doing this requires a form of metacognition, becoming aware of your thoughts and trying to make conscious decisions about which thoughts to prioritize. It was hard for him at first, it took us several sessions to kind of for this to sink in, but it was the idea that there's a part of us that goes through a trauma, like losing your parent at the age of 13 or being in combat and seeing your close friend die
这种形式的疗法旨在重塑痛苦事件在你心中的核心地位。它不再是主要的吸引力，而是退居背景。你的心智。不再是主要的吸引力，现在它处于背景中。你试着专注于其他活动、其他目标。痛苦并没有消失，但它已经从画面的第一排移到了第三排。这样做需要一种元认知形式，即意识到你的想法，并试着对优先考虑哪些想法做出有意识的决定。起初对他是很难的，我们花了几个疗程才让这个概念深入人心，但这个想法是：我们内心有一部分经历过创伤，比如在13岁时失去父母，或者在前线看到你的挚友死在
right next to you on the front lines, that is unharmed because you could notice that memory of what they looked like and what it was like to touch the blood on their body and what it was like to see, you know, the little bristles of hair on your mother who's dying from cancer because you could notice that memory, there's a part of you that's going to observe that. And so that part of you that that observer's self, is unharmed. So the idea of, imagine if you're flying the wall watching this from the outside, it taps into that observer's self, and then you can look at things with a little bit more
你身边的前线，那一部分是没有受损的，因为你可以注意到他们长相的记忆，以及触摸他们身体上血液的感觉，以及看到死于癌症的母亲脸上细小发丝的感觉，因为你可以注意到那个记忆，你身上有一部分会去观察它。所以你身上的那个观察者自我，是没有受损的。所以这个想法是，想象如果你是墙上的苍蝇从外部观看这一切，它会触及那个观察者自我，然后你可以带着更多的
just doisys. Intuitively, this makes sense. Instead of spending a lot of time trying to avoid emotional pain, focusing on pleasurable activities can deprioritize the role of pain in your life. Many people do this, of course, even without therapy or psychological training. Todd himself, in response to his mother's death death had turned to weightlifting and music. Todd and his colleagues ran studies with veteran suffering from PTSD and people with social anxiety disorder to show that patients who spend less time trying to escape the distress in their head
超然来看待事物。直觉上，这是有道理的。与其花大量时间试图逃避情感上的痛苦，不如专注于令人愉快的活动，从而降低痛苦在你生活中的重要性。当然，许多人即使没有接受过治疗或心理学培训，也会这样做。托德本人在母亲去世后，曾转向举重和音乐。托德和他的同事对患有PTSD的退伍军人和患有社交焦虑症的人进行了研究，结果表明，那些花较少时间试图逃避脑海中痛苦的人，
and more time engaged with the world had better outcomes. So there are things we can do in terms of defining what we are striving for in everyday life and building a life that matches up with our values where maybe we don't have to work with any of the psychological symptoms that are bothering us. As opposed to trying to reduce social anxiety, the fear that your perceived laws will be exposed visible to other people, and you'll be rejected because of them. That's the core of social anxiety. We wondered, if they're pursuing their primary purpose in life, what does their days look like one day after the other? And we found that for those people with significant impairing social anxiety in everyday life.
而花更多时间与世界互动的人，会有更好的结果。因此，在定义我们在日常生活中努力追求的目标以及建立与我们价值观相匹配的生活方面，我们可以做一些事情，也许我们不必处理任何困扰我们的心理症状。与试图减少社交焦虑相反，这种焦虑源于担心别人会发现你的感知缺陷，并因此遭到拒绝。那是社交焦虑的核心。我们想知道，如果他们追求生活中的主要目标，日复一日的生活会是什么样子？我们发现，对于那些在日常生活中存在严重社交焦虑障碍的人来说。
If they devoted considerable effort on a given day to their primary purpose in life, maybe it was like to be really present around their kids, maybe it was to be very compassionate with coworkers. On those days, they had over a 20% bump in their level of meaning and joy in everyday life, they had nearly a 15% increase in their positive emotions on that day and a 10% drop in their social anxiety symptoms even though they weren't doing anything to try to reduce their social anxiety. Notice however, that this technique is only one step removed from trying to avoid distress and pain. Instead of taking your pain and jamming it back down your throat, you focus on something that isn't your pain.
如果他们在某一天为生活中的主要目标付出了相当大的努力，也许是真正陪伴在孩子身边，也许是对同事非常富有同情心。在那些日子里，他们在日常生活中的意义感和快乐水平跃升了20%以上，那天的积极情绪增加了近15%，社交焦虑症状下降了10%，尽管他们并没有做任何试图减少社交焦虑的事情。然而请注意，这种技术与试图逃避痛苦和痛苦之间只差一步。与其把痛苦塞回喉咙里，你不如专注于那些不是痛苦的事情。
Focusing on positive goals that move your distress off to one side is certainly better than drowning your pain with alcohol and drugs, but it still has the central goal of keeping distress at bay. The more taught thought about it however, the more he started to see that there was a deeper thread that connected people who seemed to do well after physical and psychological setbacks. They weren't just able to deprioritize distress by focusing on something else. They seem to be able to endure distress. You know, one of my favorite studies is by a friend of mine, Marcel Bonn Miller,
专注于那些将你的痛苦推到一边的积极目标，当然比用酒精和毒品淹没痛苦要好，但它的核心目标仍然是将痛苦拒之门外。然而，托德越是思考这个问题，他就越开始看到一条更深层的线索，连接着那些在经历身体和心理挫折后表现良好的人。他们不仅能够通过专注于别的事情来降低痛苦的优先级。他们似乎还能够忍受痛苦。你知道，我最喜欢的研究之一是我的朋友马塞尔·邦米勒（Marcel Bonn Miller）做的，
and he was interested in people that have a dependence on pot or marijuana. And wanted to know, for people that want to quit, what's predicting whether they relapse one or two days after starting? And he finds that on the very first day of committing to quitting, if you break people down by levels of distressed tolerance, those people that are intolerant of the withdrawal symptoms, that 63% of them end up relapsing after one single day of quitting. Where those people that are able to tolerate distress, you get only 32% of people relapsing. That's a huge difference. And we see this with obesity, we see it with
他对比对大麻或大麻有依赖的人很感兴趣。他想知道，对于想要戒毒的人来说，是什么在预测他们在开始戒烟一两天后是否会复发？他发现，在致力于戒烟的第一天，如果你按痛苦耐受水平对人们进行分类，那些对戒断症状不耐受的人中，有63%的人在戒烟仅仅一天后最终复发。而那些能够忍受痛苦的人中，只有32%的人复发。这是一个巨大的差异。我们在肥胖问题上也看到了这一点，我们看到
people in terms of their comfort about the exposed to ideas from the opposing political party, the people that can better tolerate distress, are more open and receptive to new ways of behaving, and new ways of other people acting towards them. All of this applies to positive things too. Think about starting a new exercise program, or a new job, or moving to a new country. Each of these can bring rich benefits to your life, but each of them also comes with distress, at least at first. What are the effects of trying to avoid distress on our long-term well-being and success? Is it really helpful when friends and family and co-workers do all they can to shield us
人们对于接触来自反对党观点时的安适感，能够更好地忍受痛苦的人，对新的行为方式以及他人对待他们的新方式更加开放和包容。所有这一切也适用于积极的事情。想想开始一个新的锻炼计划、一份新工作，或者搬到一个新国家。这些都可以给你的生活带来丰富的益处，但它们中的每一个也会带来痛苦，至少一开始是这样。试图逃避痛苦对我们长期幸福和成功的长期影响是什么？当朋友、家人和同事尽一切努力保护我们免受痛苦时，这真的有帮助吗？
from pain? It's a misunderstanding of what leads humans to develop strengths and grow. I mean, if you think about it, there are so many positive consequences of pain that people pursue them intentionally. So, think of first dates, roller coasters, horror movies, spicy foods, competition. These are all events where they up-regulate the negative emotions we experience, but many of us like them because they give us an opportunity to show our metal. They give us an opportunity to see what capacities do I have at my disposal. And the way it's like to think about this, it's like safely testing
这是对导致人类发展力量和成长因素的误解。我的意思是，如果你仔细想想，痛苦有那么多积极的后果，以至于人们会有意追求它们。所以，想想第一次约会、过山车、恐怖电影、辛辣食物、竞争。这些都是会加剧我们经历的负面情绪的活动，但我们中的许多人喜欢它们，因为它们给我们提供了一个展示我们骨气（metal）的机会。它们给我们提供了一个机会去看看我手头有哪些能力。我的理解方式是，这就像在安全地测试
the alarm system in your mind and body. Now that it's safe watching a horror movie, maybe you can handle a little bit better when you get exposed to a haunted house and then maybe even better when you get exposed to a stranger asking you buy it three o'clock in the morning on a random Tuesday. We've talked a lot about the idea of emotional distress and emotional discomfort Todd and ways to not escape this emotional distress but to be able to sit with it, to be able to deal with it. I'm wondering if this has any correlates in the physical world, is learning how to deal with physical discomfort, connected at all with our ability to deal with emotional discomfort?
你心智和身体里的警报系统。现在看恐怖电影是安全的，也许当你接触到鬼屋时你能更好地应对，然后也许当你遇到一个在某个随意的周二凌晨三点向你搭话的陌生人时，你能更好地应对。我们讨论了很多关于情感痛苦和情感不适的概念，托德，以及如何不逃避这种情感痛苦而是能够与它共存、能够处理它的方法。我想知道这在物理世界中是否有任何对应物，学习如何处理身体不适与我们处理情感不适的能力有联系吗？
Yeah, this is a societal problem that my co-author Robert Buses was, either an I call, comfort addiction. It's one of the bizarre byproducts of economic prosperity. You have all the things that you described. Because of all the safety, because of all the security, we become psychologically weaker. All of a sudden, sitting on an airplane for a two-hour ride is unbearable and sitting through a presentation from a coworker where you don't get to speak is you can't resist the temptation of, you know, drawing on a piece of paper or whipping out your phone or just anything else of the van listening.
是的，这是我和我的合著者罗伯特·布塞斯（Robert Biswas-Diener）称之为“舒适上瘾”的社会问题。这是经济繁荣的怪异副产品之一。你拥有了你所描述的所有这些东西。由于所有的安全，由于所有的保障，我们在心理上变得更加虚弱。突然间，在飞机上坐两个小时是难以忍受的，听同事做你不能发言的演讲，你也无法抗拒去在一张纸上乱涂乱画或掏出手机的诱惑，或者除了听之外做任何其他事情的诱惑。
And the consequences are we are able to have less mental and physical stamina. We tend to be more selfish, and we have greater difficulty of pursuing long-term goals what Angela Duckworth calls, you know, being greedy. In his life and his research, Todd had now come a long way. He started out like many people, believing that distress was best suppressed and hidden away. Then he found it was possible to deprioritize the role of distress and focus instead on positive goals and values. The next step was the discovery that you could actually sit with distress, without believing it would destroy you. If you think of distress as being an alarm, Todd's initial response was to try and turn the alarm off. In his work with the Vietnam War vet and other patients,
其后果是，我们的精神和体力耐力都在下降。我们往往变得更加自私，并且在追求长期目标方面有更大的困难，安吉拉·达克沃斯（Angela Duckworth）称之为“贪婪”。在生活和研究中，托德现在已经走了很长一段路。他和许多人一样，一开始认为最好压抑并隐藏痛苦。然后他发现，降低痛苦的优先级并转而专注于积极的目标和价值观是可能的。下一步是发现你实际上可以与痛苦共存，而不必相信它会摧毁你。如果你认为痛苦是一个警报，托德最初的反应是试图关闭警报。在他与越战老兵和其他患者的工作中，
he realized that you could leave the alarm blurring in the background, but turn your attention to something else. That was followed by the discovery that people who do especially well at difficult challenges in life seem to be able to do more than deprioritize their distress. They seem to be able to endure the blaring discomfort of the alarm. There was one final discovery to be made. The first stage is where we tend to avoid these uncomfortable thoughts and feelings. We don't want contact with them. The second one is what we've been talking about is we can tolerate negative experiences, but that's kind of like white knuckling our way through a rollercoaster ride.
他意识到你可以让警报在背景中呼叫，但将注意力转向别的事情。随之而来的发现是，那些在生活困难挑战中表现格外好的人，似乎不仅仅是降低了痛苦的优先级。他们似乎能够忍受警报刺耳的不适感。还有一个最后的发现有待揭开。第一阶段是我们倾向于避免这些不舒服的想法和感受。我们不想与它们接触。第二阶段是我们一直在谈论的，我们可以忍受负面体验，但这有点像咬紧牙关熬过过山车。
And so the third day is the acceptance phase, where you embrace that this is a part of being human and a part of life. But then there's another level that almost nobody's been talking about in psychology. We discovered is has really good power in predicting high performance and high levels of flourishing in life. And that's harnessing negative emotions as fuel and motivation to push us to higher levels of effort and progress towards the goals we care about. To be clear, Todd is not suggesting we embrace masochism or pain for pain's sake.
所以第三阶段是接受阶段，你接受这是身为人类的一部分，也是生活的一部分。但还有另一个层次，心理学几乎没人谈论过。我们发现它在预测高绩效和生活中高度繁荣方面具有真正强大的力量。那就是将负面情绪作为燃料和动力，推动我们付出更高水平的努力，并朝着我们在乎的目标取得进展。需要明确的是，托德并不是建议我们拥抱马祖金主义（受虐狂）或为了痛苦而痛苦。
It makes sense to be vigilant to trauma and to choose activities that make us feel happy. The goal here is not to be terrified or to fall in love with pain. Rather, it's not to let the desire to avoid pain cause us to forget our values and our goals. One set of experiments, led by psychologist Martin Seligman, showed how this worked when it came to something many of us think of doing, but that few of us actually do. Writing a letter of gratitude to someone who has meant a lot to us, and then reading the letter allowed to that person. What's it like to share this letter? What's it like to wait for someone's
对创伤保持警惕并选择让我们感到快乐的活动是有道理的。这里的目标不是惊恐万状或爱上痛苦。相反，是不让渴望逃避痛苦的心理导致我们忘记我们的价值观和目标。由心理学家马丁·塞利格曼（Martin Seligman）领导的一组实验表明，当涉及到许多人想做但很少有人真正去做的事情时，这一点是如何起作用的。给对我们意义重大的人写一封感恩信，然后把这封信大声读给那个人听。分享这封信是什么感觉？等待别人
response? And their response might not be the response you want is just like the story of me at age 13 walking through the hallway. For the first time after my mom passed away, people don't necessarily know what to do when you give all these beautiful compliments to somebody. And when people come back from reading these letters, they talk about how it's awkward, how they were anxious, how they were shaking, some of them were crying because they were so damn uncomfortable in the experience. It is very awkward really letting yourself Share to another person that I can't get through life without the benefits that you afforded me and in some way
回应是什么感觉？他们的回应可能不是你想要的，就像我13岁时走过走廊的故事一样。在我妈妈去世后第一次，当你对某人给予所有这些美好的赞美时，人们不一定知道该怎么做。当人们读完这些信回来时，他们会谈到它是多么尴尬，他们是如何焦虑，他们是如何发抖，其中一些人甚至在哭，因为他们在这种经历中感到太该死的不舒服了。真正让自己向另一个人分享“没有你给予我的恩惠，我无法度过人生”是非常尴尬的，某种程度上
We are interdependent and I'm not a self-sufficient person fully. I need you I Crave your company and I've benefited from your company I need you. I crave your company and I've benefited from your company. The really bizarre part is how much laughter and joy was in the classroom as people were sharing this very similar experience. I understand that you've run a study comparing the effects of reading a gratitude letter out loud to a benefactor as these students did, versus writing down those sentiments in a private gratitude journal.
我们是相互依存的，我并不是一个完全自给自足的人。我需要你，我渴望你的陪伴，我从你的陪伴中受益。最诡异的部分是，当人们分享这种非常相似的体验时，教室里充满了笑声和快乐。据我所知，你做过一项研究，比较了像这些学生那样大声向恩人朗读感恩信的效果，与在私人感恩日记中写下这些情感的效果。
What do you find taught? Yeah, this is led by my amazing colleagues and posthin pollant. And what we want to know is, what's the best way for extracting the pleasure, the meeting, the fulfillment from a gratitude experience? Is it from journaling on a regular basis about all the affordances that you have in your life from other people, from benefactors, or is it from giving this letter and reading it to another person? And what we found was people experience more joy and meaning and stronger social bonds after sharing this gratitude letter and having this conversation about
托德，你发现了什么？是的，这是在我的优秀同事和波欣·波兰特的带领下进行的。我们想知道的是，从感恩体验中提取快乐、意义和成就感的最佳方式是什么？是通过定期在日记中写下生活中来自其他人、来自恩人的所有恩惠，还是通过把这封信给另一个人并读给他听？我们发现，在分享了这封信并就这封信进行交流之后，人们体验到了更多的快乐、意义和更强的社会联系，
this letter than compared to journaling which is this intru personal activity. But it's more anxiety provoking, it's more confusing, it's more ambivalent, and so this is one of the reasons why people don't pursue this higher difficulty activity, but this exactly the activity that builds this gratitude muscle where it becomes more of a habit that can not only give you good moments, but produce these really positive healthy relationships. I mean it's another example of where if you're able to sit with the uncomfortable emotion for a bit, you can actually scale a much higher psychological and emotional peak. In some ways we can think of all this in three simple parts.
而相比之下，日记则是一种人内（intrapersonal）活动。但这会引发更多焦虑、更混乱、更矛盾，所以这也是人们不愿追求这种高难度活动的原因之一，但这恰恰是构建这种感恩肌肉的活动，它会变得更像一种习惯，不仅能给你带来美好的时刻，还能产生这些非常积极健康的联系。我的意思是，这是另一个例子，如果你能够暂时与不舒服的情绪共存，你实际上可以攀登更高心理和情感的山峰。在某种程度上，我们可以把这一切看作三个简单的部分。
One is noticing and normalizing the difficult emotions that arise. In this case, we're talking about the anxiety of expressing deep intimacies in a gratitude letter. Then there's, as you're saying, sit with that. And play with it, work with it, be curious about these emotions that arise. And then it's taken another perspective, and that's the beauty of this conversation, is saying, who might not like the feeling? It might not feel good, but it's going to do good.
一是注意并正常化出现的困难情绪。在这种情况下，我们谈论的是在感恩信中表达深厚亲密关系的焦虑。然后，正如你所说，与它共存。与它玩耍，与它合作，对这些出现的情绪保持好奇。然后是采取另一种视角，这也是这次对话的美妙之处，即说：谁可能不喜欢这种感觉？它可能感觉不好，但这会带来好事。
And that's really what we're looking for is, how do we construct a life where there is stable architecture where there are sustained building blocks for the things we care about playfulness, feelings of competence, feelings of belonging, feelings of autonomy, feelings of satisfaction, and it tends to be on average that when you go through the negative emotional experiences, you can get the greatest strengths and the greatest outcomes. In 1963, the Reverend Martin Luther King, Jr. was arrested during civil rights protests in Birmingham, Alabama. On his second day in jail, he was passed a copy of the Birmingham News.
这确实是我们正在寻找的：我们如何构建一个生活，其中拥有稳定的架构，为我们在乎的事情（游戏性、胜任感、归属感、自主感、满足感）提供持续的构建模块，通常平均而言，当你经历负面情绪体验时，你可以获得最强大的力量和最好的结果。1963年，小马丁·路德·金牧师在阿拉巴马州伯明翰的民权抗议活动中被捕。在入狱的第二天，有人递给他一份《伯明翰新闻报》。
It featured a full-page letter about the protests signed by a group of white clergymen. This letter advised protesters that their actions were unwise and untimely. King later said, when I read it, I became so concerned and even upset and at point so righteously indignant that I decided to answer the letter. The result was King's famous letter from Birmingham Jail. King later read that letter aloud. I want to play you a clip-tot. Non-violent direct action seeks to create such a crisis and foster such a tension that a community which has constantly refused to negotiate is forced to confront the issue. It seeks so to dramatize the issue that it can no longer be ignored. My sighting the creation of tension as part of the work of the nonviolent resistor may sound rather shocking, but I must confess that I am not afraid of the word tension. I have earnestly opposed violent tension.
上面有一封关于抗议活动的整版信件，由一群白人神职人员签署。这封信建议抗议者他们的行动是不明智且不合时宜的。金后来写道，当我读到它时，我变得非常关切，甚至心烦意乱，有时甚至正义感十足地愤怒，以至于我决定回复这封信。结果就是金著名的《伯明翰监狱来信》。金后来大声宣读了这封信。我想放一段音频片段，托德。非暴力直接行动旨在制造这样一场危机并激化这样一种紧张局势，以至于一个不断拒绝谈判的社区被迫面对这个问题。它试图将问题戏剧化，使其不再被忽视。我将制造紧张局势视为非暴力抵抗工作的一部分，听起来可能相当令人震惊，但我必须坦白，我不害怕“紧张”这个词。我坚决反对暴力的紧张局势。
But that is a type of constructive nonviolent tension which is necessary for growth. It seems that King here is talking about the same idea at a societal level, Todd. We have an impulse to turn away from anything that produces distress, to turn away from what King would call tension, but he's arguing you cannot have growth and change without some amount of distress, without some amount of tension. I mean, he's encapsulating this great body of discoveries. And let me just pose a few questions, and every one of the answers to this question is that it is better to experience tension and be south of neutral in terms of your emotional experience. Which emotion is better at detecting deception?
但有一种建设性的非暴力紧张局势，是成长所必需的。金在这里似乎是在社会层面上谈论同样的理念，托德。我们有一种冲动，想要避开任何产生痛苦的事物，避开金所说的“紧张”，但他的论点是，没有一定程度的痛苦，没有一定程度的紧张，你就无法获得成长和改变。我的意思是，他总结了这一伟大的发现主体。让我提出几个问题，对每个问题的回答都是：体验紧张并在情感体验的中性线以下，其实更好。哪种情绪更擅长识破欺骗？
Which is better at producing persuasive messages? Which is better at restoring your social standing after a moral failing, which is better at stimulating effort and performance, which is better for having less selfish behavior in groups, which is better for soliciting cooperation and support and finding allies for civil rights causes, for any causes. Every one of these questions, it is better to be in a mild moderate state of anger or sadness or irritability than being happy and yet this nuanced emotional palette of tools. We suppress it, we can conceal it, or we pretend that it's better to be happy because that's what we think society wants us to be.
哪种情绪更擅长产生说服力的信息？哪种情绪更擅长在道德失范后恢复你的社会地位？哪种情绪更能刺激努力和表现？哪种情绪能让群体中的自私行为减少？哪种情绪能更好地招募合作与支持，为民权事业、为任何事业寻找盟友？对于所有这些问题，处于轻度到中度愤怒、悲伤或烦躁的状态，要好过仅仅是快乐，然而这种细微的情感工具调色板，我们却将其压抑、掩盖，或者假装快乐比较好，因为我们认为那是社会希望我们成为的样子。
Todd Cashton writes, Too often, our strategies to cope with distress, while providing momentary relief, bring us further away from the life we want and from our values. Distress is an inevitable human experience that is not inherently problematic. Distress itself does not impair functioning and well-being. The culprit is unhealthy attempts to escape distress when time and effort could be spent elsewhere in meaningful activity. When we come back, how to build a capacity to tolerate emotional distress?
托德·卡斯顿写道：通常，我们应对痛苦的策略在提供暂时缓解的同时，却使我们离想要的生活和价值观越来越远。痛苦是不可避免的人类经历，它本身并非天生就有问题。痛苦本身并不会损害功能和幸福感。罪魁祸首是不健康的试图逃避痛苦的行为，而这些时间和精力本来可以花在别处的有意义活动上。当我们回来时，如何建立承受情绪痛苦的能力？
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In day-to-day life, most of us have an instinctive desire to avoid pain. This makes sense. Pain is, well, painful. The problem, however, is that constantly seeking to avoid pain and distress can cause us to lead constricted lives and keep us from reflecting our deepest values. Psychologist Todd Cashton works at George Mason University. He's the author of the Upside of your Dark Side,
您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。在日常生活中，我们大多数人都有逃避痛苦的本能愿望。这合乎情理。痛苦嘛，就是痛苦的。然而，问题在于，不断寻求逃避痛苦和折磨会导致我们过着局促的生活，并使我们无法反映我们最深层的价值观。心理学家托德·卡斯顿在乔治梅森大学工作。他是《黑暗面的优势》一书的作者，
while being your whole self, not just your good self, drive success and fulfillment. Some time ago Todd, someone pointed out to you that as a state employee in Virginia, you had access to some information. What was this information? Yeah, after a few years of working as a professor, someone told me that because we're state employees, it's transparent, whatever one salary is.
这本书探讨了如何做完整的自己，而不仅仅是优秀的那一面，来推动成功和成就感。不久前，托德，有人指出，作为弗吉尼亚州的州雇员，你可以查阅某些信息。这是什么信息？是的，在做了几年教授后，有人告诉我，因为我们是州雇员，所以任何人的薪水都是透明的。
And I downloaded a file of whatever one makes. And I found that the salary I was making was not commiserate with what I was producing and how much effort and how much time I was devoting to my work. And there's some metrics as a professor in terms of the amount of articles you publish, how prestigious those outlets are where you publish it, and how many times you give a talk to a large audience, and all the numbers showed that it was absurd how low my salary was compared to other people. I'm wondering how this may do feel when you saw this information on this spreadsheet.
然后我下载了一份文件，看看别人都在赚多少。我发现我的薪水与我的产出、付出的努力以及投入工作的时间完全不成正比。作为教授，有一些衡量标准，比如你发表的文章数量、发表的刊物有多高的声望、你在大型观众面前做过多少次演讲，所有的数字都表明，与其他人相比，我的薪水低得离谱。我很想知道，当你看到电子表格里的这些信息时，你是什么感觉。
Well, you have a few thoughts that pop into your head. So one is that I'm not worthy of making as much money as these people. They've been around longer. I should just be waiting until it's my turn. Maybe I'm not as good as I think I am. Maybe my salary is indicative of what my value is and I have an inflated sense of self-worth. And you also feel bitterness and you feel uncomfortable with the idea of, I am one of the lowest paid people in a room of 80, and by no means do I view myself as number 79. So you came up with a number of psychological techniques to process how you
嗯，你的脑海里会涌现出一些想法。首先是觉得自己不配赚和这些人一样多的钱。他们资历更深。我应该等着轮到我。也许我没有自己想象的那么好。也许我的薪水正说明了我的价值，我有一种过高的自我价值感。你也会感到痛苦，并且对这种想法感到不舒服：在一群 80 人的房间里，我是薪水最低的人之一，但我绝不认为自己是第 79 名。所以你想出了一系列心理技巧来处理你当时的
were feeling, and one of those was something called cognitive diffusion. Explain this to me, Todd. Yeah, this is about viewing thoughts in a more accurate, representative way. So you look at thoughts as if this is something that the brain is producing. And just like a friend who might give you advice that might be good advice, it might be bad advice, your brain is the same way. It's just constantly churning out thoughts and feelings and sensations. And you separate the thought from you, the thinker. And when you create this space, there's room to take actions that don't match up with
感受，其中之一就是所谓的认知解离。托德，给我解释一下这个。是的，这是以一种更准确、更有代表性的方式来看待想法。所以你看待想法时，会把它当作大脑产生的一种产物。就像一个可能会给你建议的朋友，他的建议可能是好建议，也可能是坏建议，你的大脑也是如此。它只是不断地产生想法、感觉和知觉。你将想法与作为思考者的你分离开来。当你创造出这个空间时，就有余地去采取那些与
the thought itself. And so when you have a thought such as, I'm not worthy of making a lot of money. And then you add in front of that, I notice some having this thought that I don't deserve to be making a lot of money. It's just like being the fly in the wall of viewing yourself in a social situation, you recognize it's like, oh, it's not going to stop me from crafting an email or making an opportunity to actually schedule an appointment with someone to actually talk about my pay salary. A second strategy you used was south affirmation.
想法本身不一致的行动。因此，当你产生这样的想法时，比如，我不配赚很多钱。然后你在前面加上，我注意到自己有这样一个想法，即我不配赚很多钱。这就像作为一个旁观者在社交场合审视自己，你认识到，哦，这不会阻止我起草一封电子邮件，也不会阻止我创造机会去预约某人，真正谈谈我的薪水。你使用的第二个策略是自我肯定。
Walk me through this strategy, Todd. So this is when you basically clarify that your identity is bigger than any stressor and to inflate the size and the complexity of who you are. And so for me, I identify strongly with bravery. And you start to note very clearly your track record of being brave. And so, for example, you would see that I had lost my three bottom teeth and their fake
托德，带我了解一下这个策略。所以，这基本上是澄清你的身份比任何压力源都要宏大，并且去放大你的规模和复杂性。对园区而言，我强烈认同勇敢这一品质。然后你开始非常清楚地记下你表现勇敢的事迹。所以，比方说，你会发现我失去了下排的三颗牙齿，而且它们是假的，
because freshman year of college and I saw a guy knock out his girlfriend and I stood in front of her and would not let him near her again. Because I don't know how to fight, I took quite a shot in the face and three of my teeth were lost in that battle. And you think of events like that and you clarify exactly what your identity is composed of that can last a cross time in space and it centers you to realize that no threat is going to have that much of a neutron blast to my identity because it's so large and it's so sophisticated.
因为在大一的时候，我看到一个家伙打倒了他的女朋友，我挡在她前面，不让他靠近她。因为我不会打架，我的脸挨了重重的一击，在那场战斗中我失去了三颗牙齿。你会想到这样的事情，并准确地阐明你的身份是由什么组成的，这些品质可以跨越时空而长存，它让你意识到没有任何威胁会对我的身份造成毁灭性的打击，因为它是如此宏大和复杂。
You know it's almost like you are a general who's sort of marshaling troops, but also assessing the threat. So you have these negative emotions, these emotions of feeling unworthy or disappointment or anger, but you're not swept up in those emotions. You're basically saying, all right, let me evaluate them. Let me test them to see how accurate they are. Let me figure out how much I should be paying attention to these different emotions. And then you're cataloging all of the strengths
你知道，这就像你是一位正在调兵遣将、同时也在评估威胁的将军。所以你有这些负面情绪，这些感到不配、失望或愤怒的情绪，但你并没有被这些情绪所吞没。你基本上是在说，好吧，让我评估一下它们。让我测试它们，看看它们有多准确。让我弄清楚我应该对这些不同的情绪给予多少关注。然后你开始盘点你所拥有的所有优势，
that you have that you could bring to this battle. What do you think about this analogy? That in some ways you're stepping back from the field of battle rather than being swept up in what's going on and essentially assessing what your next move should be. Yeah, no, I like that. And another analogy that works is
这些优势可以带到这场战斗中。你觉得这个比喻怎么样？在某种程度上，你是从战场上退后一步，而不是被正在发生的事情所吞没，本质上是在评估你的下一步行动应该是什么。是的，我不讨厌这个。另一个有效的比喻是，
you are doing an audit of what resources and capabilities psychologically, socially, and even financially, and emotionally. Do you have your disposal irrespective of what pops up in terms of a difficult demanding situation.
你正在盘点自己在心理、社会、经济甚至情感上拥有哪些资源和能力。无论面对什么困难和苛刻的局势，你都能听凭调遣。
So once you did this audit both of the emotions that you were experiencing as well as the strengths and virtues that you knew that you possessed, what did you do next? I scudged an appointment with the chair of my department. And they said that, listen, you'll eventually get a higher salary as you spend a longer number of years in the department. And I said, if I was dissatisfied with what you just said, would you be okay if I went one step above you and made the appointment to meet with the dean of the entire college? And they said, yes, like it's, it it's most people don't do it, but sure. But this is where that affirmation of bravery allows you to withstand the discomfort of being told.
所以，一旦你对你所经历的情绪以及你知道自己拥有的力量和美德进行了全面盘点，你接下来做了什么？我预约了系主任。他们说，听着，随着你在系里年头的增加，你最终会得到更高的薪水。我说，如果我对你刚才的话不满意，如果我越级直接预约了整个学院的院长见面，你介意吗？他们说，可以，就像，大多数人不会这么做，但当然可以。但这就是勇敢的肯定让你能够承受被告知的不适感的地方。
You're not doing what other people do when they feel they're not being paid adequately. And when I made an appointment with the dean, before I stepped into his office, I created a spreadsheet of everyone who is making more money than me. And then I basically denoted all their productivity over the past three years compared to myself. In terms of number of publications, presentations, how much grant money they brought in, these are the metrics of a researcher. And the dean was laughing, was saying, you put a lot of effort in, and to be honest, the data don't lie. And although I am reluctant to create a precedent where people come into my office and do this, you are the pay raise. And it gave me a substantial pay raise.
你的做法与其他人感到薪酬不公时的做法不同。当我与院长预约后，在走进他的办公室之前，我制作了一份电子表格，上面列出了所有赚钱比我多的人。然后我基本上列出了他们过去三年的生产力，并与我进行对比。就发表论文数量、演讲次数、他们拉到的科研经费而言，这些都是研究人员的衡量标准。院长笑了，说，你付出了很多努力，说实话，数据不会说谎。虽然我很不情愿开创这种先例，让人们走进我的办公室做这种事，但你就是加薪的理由。这为我争取到了相当可观的加薪。
So one important question here at Todd, which is, you know, how do we tell the difference between pain that we should learn to tolerate and pain that we should seek to eliminate? I mean, I don't think that you would tell someone who is in an abusive relationship that she should strengthen her tolerance for pain. No, and neither should you put your hand in the toaster as you're in the middle of making pop tarts. To me, it's as simple as, are these tools, and that's what emotions are. They're tools. Are they helping or hindering you in your pursuit of goals that you care about? In other words, if the emotional distress is in the service of a goal that you really care about, that's emotional distress what enduring?
那么这里有一个重要的问题，托德，那就是，我们如何区分我们应该学会忍受的痛苦和我们应该设法消除的痛苦？我的意思是，我想你不会告诉一个处于虐待关系中的人，她应该增强对痛苦的耐受力。不，你也不会在烤蛋挞的时候把手伸进烤面包机里。对我来说，事情很简单：这些工具（情绪就是工具）是否在帮助或阻碍你追求你在乎的目标？换句话说，如果情绪困扰是为了服务于一个你真正关心的目标，那么这种情绪困扰是否值得忍受？
In some ways, if you think about what's your greatest fear and for a lot of people, it's the fear of public speaking. Does the anxiety that's pushing you to want to actually say, no, I'm not going to go on stage. Does that hinder you from the goal of resenting this information that you think is valuable to impart to this audience? Is that showing respect and dignity to those people that are about to give you undivided attention. And if you ask those questions and you really grow, why is your mind evoking this particular emotional state? You'll realize it's mobilizing you for action probably not to make you avoid getting in front of these individuals. So it's been many years, Todd, since you, you know,
在某种程度上，如果你想想你最大的恐惧是什么，对很多人来说，就是公开演讲的恐惧。这种促使你想说“不，我不会上台”的焦虑，是否会阻碍你向这个观众传达你认为很有价值的信息这一目标？这是否是对即将给予你全神贯注的那些人的尊重和尊严？如果你问这些问题，并且真正去探究为什么你的大脑会唤起这种特定的情绪状态，你就会意识到它是在动员你采取行动，而不是让你去避免站在这些人面前。所以，托德，自从你年轻时逃避痛苦以来，已经过去很多年了，最近你有机会看到自己在重新审视对恐惧、痛苦和其他令人不快的情绪的想法的旅程中走得有多远，跟我聊聊你接触攀岩的经历吧。
ran away from your pain as a young man, and more recently you've had opportunities to see how far you've come in your journey to reorient the way you think about fear and distress and and other unpleasant emotions, tell me about your encounter with rock climbing. I met this guy, Matt Walker, and he knew I was an author, and he said, listen, we trade skills. Go back to the old, old school bartering is, if you teach me how to write a book, I'll teach you how to rock. Come out to Arizona, the Co-Chee Stronghold, which I knew is this great mountaineering area, and come for a five-day trip for beginners. And a book to flight went out there.
我遇到了这个人，马特·沃克，他知道我是一个作家，他说，听着，我们交换技能。回到老派的易货交易，如果你教我怎么写书，我教你怎么攀岩。来亚利桑那州的科奇要塞吧，我知道这是一个很棒的登山区，来参加一个为期五天的初学者之旅。我订了机票就去了。
And once we got there the first night and everyone introduced themselves, I realized we had very different definitions of what beginner means. Because the person next to me was an ex-Navy seal. The mother and daughter next to him had traveled to Patagonia and rock climbed all over South America. And then next to her was a, I forgot I was a professional volleyball or soccer player but they played division one ball and they were professional and then there's me who has a few
一旦我们到了那里，第一天晚上大家做自我介绍时，我意识到我们对“初学者”的定义有很大的不同。因为我旁边的人是一个前海豹突击队队员。他身边的母女俩曾去过巴塔哥尼亚，在南美洲各地攀岩。然后她旁边是一个——我忘了他是职业排球运动员还是足球运动员，但他们打过一级联赛而且是职业选手——然后是我，一个只有几次微不足道飞行记录的
replights and it is a 700 foot climb called Moby Tick. This is not what beginners should be doing. To give you an idea of 700 feet, a 700 foot climb just take an entire cold to sack every single house and then stack them on top of each other and you were climbing that and it's pretty much almost purely vertical. I just was so, I mean it's the most anxious that I think I've ever been in my entire life. After climbing for just a few hours on a practice rock, I was so nervous, I was pushing my fingers so hard in the rock that I had gone through five layers of skin. It was so bad that the first day of climbing, Matt had to take crazy glue and pour it over all of my fingers,
人，我们要去爬一个叫做“白鲸”（Moby Dick）的700英尺高的岩壁。这根本不应该是初学者做的事。为了让你对700英尺有个概念，700英尺高的攀岩就像把整个死胡同里的每一栋房子拿来，然后把它们叠在一起，你就是在爬那个东西，而且它几乎是完全垂直的。我当时太紧张了，可以说是我一生中最焦虑的一次。在练习岩壁上攀爬了几个小时后，我太紧张了，以至于我把手指死死地抠进岩壁里，磨破了五层皮。情况太糟糕了，以至于攀岩的第一天，马特不得不拿强力胶水倒在我的所有手指上，
so I had fake layers of skin to protect me on the climb. So on the day of the big climb, you're standing before Moby Dick, you have the 700 foot climb before you. What happens that day? I could barely even breathe. And when you're climbing with pitches, you are putting anchors into the rock and then you are as you are going up you are taking all the equipment with you to go for the next pitch and climb up the mountain and so there is no way down
这样我就有了假皮来保护我在攀岩时不受伤。所以在重大攀岩的那天，你站在白鲸岩前，面前有700英尺高的岩壁。那天发生了什么？我甚至几乎无法呼吸。当你进行分段攀岩时，你要把锚点钉进岩石里，然后随着你往上爬，你要把所有的设备随身携带，以便进行下一段攀岩并爬上山，所以一旦你到了最顶端，就没有退路了，
until you get to the very top. And Matt said this, the state into me which is listen, I can see how afraid you are. Look at your fingers. Here are the choices. Either you stand by yourself in the desert because we're all doing this and there's no one else down there. Or you climb up this mountain with your fear. And your fear is going to be your friend. And you're going to take it with you. Or your fear is going to be your enemy. And you're going to expend
除非你爬到最顶端。马特对我说了这样一番话，听着，我能看出你有多害怕。看看你的手指。现在的选择是：要么你一个人站在沙漠里，因为我们都在做这件事，下面也没有别人。要么你带着恐惧爬上这座山。你的恐惧将成为你的朋友。你要带着它一起走。否则你的恐惧就会成为你的敌人，你要付出
so much extra energy to get up this rock and you don't need to. It was like he just took off three vails of fear and defensiveness and coping mechanisms. I was like, I'm going up the rock no matter what. Why am I doing this with so much physical tension inside my body? Again slow the actions down and just do one step and one handhold at a time. And he did something further which was the last pitch before we got to the apex of the climb. He said, Todd, you're going to be the last person and you are going to not only climb, but you're going to pull the anchors out and put them into your belt as you climb, which means that
如此多的额外精力来爬上这块岩石，而你根本不需要这么做。这就像他一下子卸下了三层恐惧、防御和应对机制。我当时想：不管怎样，我都要爬上这块岩石。为什么我要让身体里带着这么多的生理紧张感做这件事？再次放慢动作，一次只做一个步骤和一个手点。他甚至还做了进一步的举动，就是在我们到达攀岩顶点前的最后一段。他说，托德，你将是最后一个，你不仅要攀岩，还要在攀岩的同时把锚点拔出来别在腰带上，这意味着
everyone is already climbed up and I am on, I don't know, 500 feet in the air, by myself, a rookie, and there's no one there to help me because everyone's already on top of the rock. And this is what we call not gradual exposure to the things that you're afraid of, for you, if you were afraid of spiders, you would start by reading Charlotte's web watching a movie of like a rack nephobia and then maybe there would be like a spider in a jar behind a locked door. This is called slutty. This is like I'm gonna drop you off in a pit of pain and despair and you're gonna fight your way out of it and I did it. Tell me what it was like to get to the top of the mountain, Don.
每个人都已经爬上去了，而我在离地500英尺的高空，孤身一人，是个新手，没有人能帮我，因为所有人都已经在岩石顶上了。这就是我们所说的，对你害怕的事物进行非渐进式的暴露。对你来说，如果你害怕蜘蛛，你会从阅读《夏洛特的网》、看一部像《狂蛛年华》这样的电影开始，然后可能在一扇锁着的门后面的罐子里会有一只蜘蛛。这叫作“突击疗法”。这就像是我要把你扔进痛苦和绝望的深渊，你要靠自己杀出一条血路，而我做到了。告诉我登上山顶是什么感觉，唐。
When we got to the cop, everybody was cheering, everybody was hugging each other. And I just said, can I just have a moment to just take this whole end. And I just wanted to sit on the edge with my legs dangling and just take like a deep breath of air and the landscape at the Co Chi stronghold. It's just this beautiful vista and I had this thought of like I know I'm strong and I know that I can persevere at tasks but I didn't know how strong and how capable I was. And then it's like, this is why you do the work. Because this sense of awe of looking at this landscape
当我们到达山顶时，每个人都在欢呼，每个人都在互相拥抱。我只是说，我能有一会儿时间来好好体会这一切吗？我只想坐在边缘，双腿悬空，深深地吸一口气，呼吸科奇要塞的风景。这简直是太美的远景了，我当时脑子里闪过这样一个想法：我知道我很坚强，我也知道我能坚持完成任务，但我不知道自己竟然如此坚强和能干。然后这就好比：这就是你为什么要做这些努力的原因。因为这种眺望风景的敬畏感
and the sun sets, you just dream of sitting and watching. It's just the reminder of the richness and the vitality we're shooting for and that the pain is worth the effort. Todd Cashden is a psychologist at George Mason University. He is the author of the Art of Inceboardenation, how to dissent and defy effectively, and the upside of your dark side, while being your whole self, not just your good self, drive success and fulfillment. Todd, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
和日落，正是你做梦都想坐下来观看的景象。它只是提醒我们，我们所追求的是丰富和活力，而这些痛苦是值得付出努力的。托德·卡什丹是乔治森大学的心理学家。他是《叛逆的艺术：如何有效地异议与反抗》以及《黑暗面的优势：做完整的自己，而不只是好自己，才能推动成功与成就》的作者。托德，谢谢你今天做客“隐秘大脑”。
Thanks for the therapy session. You're welcome. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
谢谢你给我做的心理治疗。不客气。“隐秘大脑”由隐秘大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐秘大脑”的执行主编。
Our unsung hero today is listener and Hidden Brain supporter, Orilian Joga. Orelian started listening to Hidden Brain while in Texas for work training. Orelian writes, thanks to podcasting, I brought that home with me back to France. Had we been 20 years earlier, this wouldn't have been possible. Orelian, thank you for bringing Hidden Brain back to France with you and also for supporting the show. If you enjoyed today's episode and if you would like to join Oralian in supporting our work, go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, go to support.hiddenbrain.org to help us build more stories like this one.
我们今天的无名英雄是听众兼“隐秘大脑”的支持者奥雷利安·乔加。奥雷利安在德克萨斯州参加工作培训时开始收听“隐秘大脑”。奥雷利安写道，多亏了播客，我把这个节目带回了法国的家。如果是在20年前，这是不可能实现的。奥雷利安，谢谢你把“隐秘大脑”带回法国，也谢谢你对节目的支持。如果你喜欢今天的节目，并且想和奥雷利安一样支持我们的工作，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。重复一遍，访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 来帮助我们制作更多这样的故事。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们回头见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。